[Music]
good morning Hank it's Thursday November
1st Hank I want to begin by
congratulating you on your raps on
yesterday um I laughed a lot that wasn't
always laughing with you but I laughed a
lot so Hank in today's video I want to
talk a little bit about nerdfighters
Hank you know what I really like what I
like more than anything else in the
entire world nerdfighters I have never
met a nerdfighter I didn't like I like
going to my pants and seeing what
they're talking about I like reading
their comments I like watching their
videos I like it when they send me
pictures so from all over the world this
like nation has been built out of nerds
I mean it's a small nation it's like
Lichtenstein but Hank there are two
kinds of nerdfighters that I like better
than all of the other nerdfighters in
the world first little ones like last
night Hank there was this little six
year old nerdfighter who was
trick-or-treating and he came up to my
door and he said trick-or-treat and I
said what are you dressed as and he said
that taught simois and I was like are
you louis xiv and he said we
trick-or-treat little nerdfighters so
cute
and Hank my other kind of favorite
nerdfighter is when a nerdfighter finds
another nerdfighter and they fall a
nerdfighter like and Hank I happen to
have inside information that that
precise thing has recently happened one
of our secret siblings I'm not going to
reveal his or her name because she asked
me darn it
not to has just started seeing another
nerdfighter a somewhat prominent
nerdfighter I'm not naming any names all
I'm going to show you Hank is that both
of these people are so awesome that if
and when they're awesome collides it
could result in a kind of nuclear chain
reaction of Awesome that could
potentially lead to world peace but Hank
there is a problem can you guess what
the problem is Hank it's geography the
difference between nerdfighteria and say
Lichtenstein by the way do you think
there's any way we could take over
Lichtenstein I mean I know that nerds
aren't known for their military
capabilities but does Lichtenstein even
have a standing army is that
Lichtenstein is located in one place
whereas nerdfighteria is located in like
30,000 different places which is fine
because there are still great places in
nerdfighteria to hang out like my pants
hey the only problem is that
occasionally you need to do something
other than hangout like you need to like
touch and hug and that's all let's make
it perfectly clear for all the young
nerdfighters out there mommy and daddy
nerdfighters don't do anything but touch
and hug Hank our secret sibling and her
nerdfighter boy are separated by
geography
fortunately Hank it's a geography that
can be transversed by train but hey
they're not business people they're
nerdfighters so they don't have any
money
without the money they can't get on the
train without the train they can't bring
together they're awesome and so I heard
about this and I was so upset Hank
because like it's like my second
favorite kind of nerdfighter right
behind bird fighter babies but Hank then
I remembered we created a foundation to
deal with this very kind of problem so
Hank we're gonna do it there will be
complexities there will be complications
it's gonna take a little bit but we're
gonna do it it's gonna cost someone
around 100 bucks and a penny
nerdfighters want to contribute to the
project they're welcome to do so at
brotherhood to comm Hank here's the
semi-abstract pumpkin painting that
Sarah and I made of you last night by
the way when I say Sarah and I I mean
almost entirely Sarah I'll see you on
Monday no wait tomorrow
pS in indianapolis indiana there is a
Subway restaurant just south of 86th
Street on ditch Road around the corner
from that subway you will find two metal
boxes something is taped to the top of
one of them if you find that something
you should report its nature and
contents immediately at Brotherhood
2.com slash my pants thus begins the
worldwide nerdfighter scavenger hunt see
you in my pants